imaginemos que tengo esta función dada
por un polinomio de grado 7 claramente
esto tiene grado 7 y me pregunto cuál es
el número posible de raíces reales de
este polinomio así que podría tener por
ejemplo 9 raíces reales u 8 reyes reales
como siempre los invito a pasar el vídeo
y tratar de descifrar esto por ustedes
mismos así que supondrá que ya lo
hicieron y vamos a pensar pues el
teorema fundamental del álgebra me dice
que siempre siempre voy a tener 7 raíces
7 raíces ahora estas raíces podrían o no
ser números reales podrían ser números
complejos aunque no fueran números
reales pero siempre tengo que tener un
total de 7 raíces por lo tanto vamos a
pensar vamos a escribir número
de raíces
países reales
número de raíces reales
y veamos podría tener siete raíces siete
raíces reales pues sí sí gráfico este
polinomio podría interceptar al eje real
siete veces no hay ningún problema ahora
podría tener seis raíces reales pues
vamos a pensar en qué significa eso para
las raíces complejas que no son reales
es más mejor vamos a escribirlo así
vamos a escribirlo como sigue vamos a
pensar en las raíces reales países
reales
por ponerlas aquí
y acá vamos a poner las raíces no reales
no reales complejas recuerden todos los
números reales son números complejos
pero hay números complejos que no son
reales por eso escribo no reales
complejas y bueno como decía pueda tener
siete raíces reales si puedo tener siete
raíces reales y entonces como tengo que
tener siete raíces en total no tendría
raíces complejas ahora que hay de seis
raíces reales pues si tengo seis raíces
reales entonces tengo que tener una raíz
compleja porque tengo que tener siete en
total pero las raíces complejas no
reales siempre vienen en pares en pares
de números complejos conjugados por lo
tanto no puedo tener sólo una tengo que
tener siempre un número par de raíces no
reales complejas así que
en este caso no se puede
qué hay de 5 raíces reales si tengo 5
raíces reales entonces tendría 2
raíces complejas no reales lo cual es
perfectamente posible una pareja de
números conjugados y creo que ya bien ya
están viendo que se forme un patrón si
tuviera 4 raíces reales entonces tendría
tres raíces complejas que no son números
reales pero eso no se puede
3 no es un número par así que no puedo
tener 4 países
qué hay de tres raíces reales pues eso
implica que tendría cuatro raíces
complejas no reales y este caso si se
puede sería una pareja de números
complejos perdón serían dos parejas de
números complejos conjugados
que hay de todas raíces reales les
implicaría 5 raíces complejas no reales
lo cual no se puede
y que hay de una raíz real pues si
tuviera una raíz final tendría seis
raíces complejas no reales lo cual sí es
posible y finalmente qué pasaría si no
tuviera raíces reales pues tendría siete
raíces complejas no reales lo cual no se
puede por lo tanto este polinomio de
grado 7 con coeficientes reales tiene
que tener al menos una raíz real